now the european commission has unveiled
its plan to
overhaul the eu's migration and asylum
system
appealing to member states to show
solidarity with one another european
countries have long disagreed about the
best way to manage
migration under the new proposals
countries like hungary and poland who
refused to accept migrants
would instead offer money equipment or
personnel to help patrol borders
the european commission president josela
fonda line says the continent must rise
to the challenge
on migration this package reflects a
fair
and reasonable balance between
responsibility
and solidarity among member states
we all share the benefits we all share
the burden this package
also reflects a very pragmatic and
realistic approach
we know that we have to build trust
among member states and
citizens confidence that we can manage
this as a union dw's alexander
phenomenon
is in brussels covering this story for
us hi alexandra
tell us more about what is in this
proposal
well as we just heard ursula fonda line
has described this proposal
as pragmatic and realistic and that is
indeed what it seems to be not an
entirely new plan revolutionary plan but
a kind of compromise acknowledging the
fact how difficult it is to find an
agreement on that issue
key takeaways here the european
commission
is abandoning the idea of mandatory
refugee quarters
requiring eu members to to take in a
certain amount of refugees or migrants
another key issue is that the european
communi
commission is saying it's important to
give up screenings for new arrivals
at the eu's external borders and that it
is
important to intensify efforts to return
those who have no right to stay
in the european union so overall i would
say
that this proposal is showing that
europe is once again
getting tougher on migrants alexander it
does really seem to be
a strategy to try to appease some of the
countries who don't want to take in
migrants so tell us more
about how some of the incentives and
compromises in this proposal work
well indeed it seems to be the strategy
here to reach out and address
the concerns of those countries who
still refuse to take in refugees and
migrants the european community
commission here is saying okay if you
are
not willing to do that that you need to
contribute in other areas key word here
is flexible
uh contributions those country will be
asked to provide money to fund
so-called reception centers or to
take over the responsibility for those
who need to be returned
to their countries because their asylum
claims were rejected
in the european union so that's an
attempt
by the european commission to to make
sure that those country
are on board and that finally an
agreement can be found
on this very sensitive issue
and alexandre just quickly what makes
the commission think that they have
the solution now because this has been
one of the most politically
sensitive issues in the european union
well when we talk to eu officials or
even german politicians they tell you
that
everywhere now everyone now understands
that
something needs to be changed and that
is their argument to say that the
chances for
an agreement right now are higher than
before
our correspondent alexander fernan
reporting for us from
brussels thank you so much
so what will this mean for migrants who
are seeking shelter
in europe let's get the perspective of
karen metz from the ngo save the
children
in brussels hi karen thank you for
joining us will this new proposal
change anything for people who are in
camps right now in greece or in italy
well um we fear that this pact uh
risk repeating some of the mistakes that
we saw in greece right now the pact
introduces a new pre-screening and
border procedure which would
um allow to member states to register
and fingerprint people and then
channel them into asylum border returns
procedures which is essentially what we
see in the hot spots in greece right now
um you know processing asylum claims or
returning people
is not so straightforward there are lots
of obstacles
and we fear that people will risk ending
up in detention
um for extended periods of time
okay so you're saying it's not much of
an improvement i mean do you think this
this new proposal will
work a lot will depend on the
willingness of
eu member states to cooperate because
even if you have these border procedures
uh
member states frontline member states
like italy greece and
um and malta will be reluctant to
cooperate if there isn't any sort of
mandatory relocation
and then they might not disembark our
ships that
have been rescued and then migrants
remain stranded
so a lot will depend on the willingness
of eu member states which in the last
five years has not been very high
indeed this has been a very divisive
issue within the european union so from
your perspective
what would be the right approach to to
create a
common approach to uh migration
well um we believe that there needs to
be a a
commonly supported solidarity mechanism
which also includes mandatory relocation
because otherwise uh member states in
the front line
will not uh cooperate we also believe
that
things can be we don't need to rely on
detention there are alternatives
um member states could immediately take
up asylum seekers at the borders
uh when they arrive without having to
place them in detention while their
asylum claims are being processed
this was actually in the dublin proposal
that was uh proposed by the european
parliament back in
2016 or 2017 but has never been picked
up
and karen you are with save the children
i have to ask i mean does there need to
be a particular
approach a strategy to help children in
camps or unaccompanied minors
yes and this is a positive thing of the
pact because
it seems that unaccompanied children and
children below the age of 12 would be
exempt from the new border procedures
that are being proposed
we of course believe that a child is
anybody below the age of 18. so we find
this this
differentiation of the age of 12 quite
arbitrary but this is good there are
some specific issues like
fast tracking family reunification maybe
providing alternatives to detention
and and improving alternative care that
are mentioned in the pact but of course
um vulnerable groups are currently also
exempt from the hot spots in greece but
they are still there so it also
it remains to be seen how this will all
work in practice
karen metz from save the children
joining us from brussels thank you very
much
you